Sonic tractor beams use loudspeakers
to create high-pressure shapes out of sound
– acoustic holograms –
that can hold, rotate, and move objects in midair.
But for years researchers have struggled to levitate
objects larger than 1/2 the wavelength of the sound.
Using a single acoustic vortex,
researchers have only been able to levitate tiny objects,
about 1.6 millimeters wide.
Larger items spin uncontrollably and are ejected.
Now, a team of engineers has figured out
how to levitate objects more than 10 times that size.
Using 192 loudspeakers,
they created two vortexes that pulse in alternating bursts
of a few milliseconds each.
This technique stops the objects spinning,
which makes them more stable and
allows the researchers to levitate objects larger
than the wavelength of the sound.
It may be a while before
such beams can be put to practical use.
But in the meantime,
scientists say that with more powerful speakers,
they might be able to hold
—and even control—astronauts in zero gravity.